l'alaska regardez bien
c'est un pays en voie de développement
photographique et je veux dire qu'il
existe encore peu l'image de ce pays en
noir et blanc surtout en blanc où le
thermomètre se permet des écarts de
température de 80 degrés entre le nord
moins 50 et le sud plus 30 qui voit
mûrir ses céréales et ses légumes en
quelques semaines par la magie d'un
ensoleillement de 20 heures par jour et
le désert lui même qui a 200 jours de la
réception parents regrettent qu'il n'y
viennent jamais personne et dit sa
solitude avec des fleurs
mais depuis le temps lointain où
l'américain le pays est aux russes 20
centimes l'hectare et le trouvait trop
cher lesca s'est enrichie et ses forêts
n'échappe pas à l'exploitation du tronc
par l'homme qui du bois mais chacun sait
cela tire de la pâte à papier de la pâte
à papier le papier monnaie et du
papier-monnaie de beaux arbres en bois
qui fournissent d'excellents pâte à
papier mais il ya autre chose en alaska
quelque chose qui ressemble à de la boue
du sable du biscuit sec quelque chose
qui ne brille pas et qui est là
aujourd'hui
la drague au pair avec l'infatigable
lenteur de l'efficacité elle a remplacé
les hommes avec leurs pioches leur
famille et leur fébrilité
elle leur a promis de remplacer l'or à
l'appel il ne demandait qu'à la croix
trois d'entre eux il n'y a pas si
longtemps trouvèrent une fortune en deux
jours
l'équivalent de 700 mille dollars dans
un temps
et suscitèrent des vocations quelques
coups de pistolet et beaucoup
d'illusions
cap ça n'empêche pas les fleurs de
s'épanouir les animaux de penser à autre
chose et l'alaska de réussir par le jeu
de l'eau et des montagnes enneigées est
plus délicate synthèse de la glace et du
miroir
à chaque pays ses monuments historiques
ramassées dans sa coquille de noix
géante
cette sorte de forteresse navale
abandonné par son équipage lance de la
rive une discrète invitation au voyage
dans l'appel inutile de ces ponts des
airs et de sans gouvernail mobile et
fait revivre les temps lointain où
l'essentiel pour nomme n'était pas
d'arriver net partie
en tout cas personne ne voudrait manquer
la promenade en bateau à aubes qui
remonte simultanément le fil de
l'histoire et celui de la rivière pour
piochant sa route liquide et sa route
carriole aquatique et surcharges un juno
la capitale le french cancan à quelque
chose de légèrement surgelés qui
n'incite pas moi le dégourdi à se
dégourdir avec le concours d'un trappeur
du piano il touche aux notes qu'avec des
gros ici la circulation ne pose pas que
tremble l'architecturé ce qu'elle est et
sert consciencieusement de support
commerce local
temps
en alaska il existe des régions dans le
relevé topographique reste à faire des
fleuves d'autant plus difficiles à
dénombrer qu'il ne couche pas toujours
voir le même lit de tous les moyens de
locomotion connu depuis peu
l'hydroglisseur qui est le juste milieu
entre le bateau et l'avion 5 cm d'eau
lui suffisent et d'aucuns les poètes
prétendent qu'il pourrait glisser sur la
rosée du matin
de la côte jusqu'au fond du klondike
d'illustrer aurifère mémoire la voie
ferrée suit la route de 1898 et vous
savez que la route de 1898 l'ancienne
piste des chercheurs d'or faubourg un
vieux rêve en chemin des paysages des
alpes des montagnes qui n'ont pas de nom
des plaines sans traces de pas des
villages de rochers des foules de sa
peau et quelquefois du rien à perte de
vue
pas de gains le train ne s'arrête qu'au
terminus à whitehorse là-bas dans une
odeur de suie de brume et de wisques
et
m
l'océan qui baigne gentiment le losc est
un monstre sans malice qui papotent
enfin qui clapotent dans les
innombrables abri offert par un étonnant
découpage de montagne directement coulé
dans la mer à un mètre du bord
le fonds est à 700 m
on a beau voyager en groupe quand je
sens couramment très seul en face de cet
interlocuteur majestueux et quelque peu
réfrigérant le paysage qui sait miroiter
ces icebergs translucide et accumule les
surprises dans son déferlement de beauté
sauvage c'est la région des glaciers
mouvante et incertaine
avec ses 40 rivière qui font un taylor
glaçons dans le silence le environnement
du vide
c'est étrange et tendu qui modifient
constamment leurs formes et leurs
couleurs commence à peine d'être
explorée
et le meilleur moyen de faire
connaissance avec cette nature province
est encore de le prendre de haut
en hélicoptère c'est lui qui relèvera le
tracé indécis de ce paysage aux contours
fuyant c'est lui qui déposera les
amateurs de ski au sommet de montagne
qui n'ont ni nom ni adresse ni mémoire
et qui ne garderons qu'un astre enlève
traces de leur passage
le ski e set ni d'où il vient ni où il
va y glisse dans l'île limité et il ne
sait pas s'il retrouvera jamais sa
pesanteur
non
où
quant à l'avion ce préposé au courrier
et à l'exploration des grands espaces
le pilote de brousse est le facteur le
camionneur l'ambulancier il transporte
le pain les vivres et munitions le
commerçant et ses échantillons
le missionnaire essebi but et sans lui
l'habitant des solitudes serez sourd et
muet
yann l alaska 12 est rude polaire et
fleuri il a longtemps vécu dans la glace
il sort avec plaisir de son hibernation
prolongée et il s'aperçoit en débarquant
des machines volantes qu'ils dépensent
déjà dans le futur qu'il a tout à
découvrir
y compris son passé
m
je peux